[Music]
welcome back to Hannity Congress is
demanding answers tonight after Politico
reported quote in its determination to
secure a nuclear deal with Iran the
Obama administration derailed an
ambitious law enforcement campaign
targeting drug trafficking by the
Iranian backed terrorist group Hezbollah
even as it was funneling cocaine into
the United States Republican Congressman
Jim Jordan and Ron de Santos are
following up on that story by sending a
letter to Attorney General Jeff Sessions
the congressmen are asking the
Department of Justice to turn over all
documents and communications related to
this matter to find out whether the
Obama administration did this to help
secure the nuclear deal with Iran
joining us now with more on this request
is congressman De Santis
a fascinating story and is so disturbing
at the same time congressman how do you
anticipate the DOJ is going to respond
to your request for documents and
information well I actually expect them
to respond favorably because this is an
important issue and if you go back to
the second term of Obama remember what
Ben Rhodes said yes the Iran deal is the
Obamacare of the second term everything
was subservient to that they did all
kinds of things to get that deal through
obviously they told a lot of falsehoods
to the American people in the process
this thing with Hezbollah who by the way
has American blood on its hands they're
one of the most lethal terrorist groups
in the Middle East you go all the way
back to the Beirut bombing of the Marine
Corps barracks in 1983 Hezbollah was the
perpetrator of that so they've been
raising wreaking havoc in the Middle
East against our allies against the
United States for decades and to make a
conscious decision to ward off a very
sophisticated task force that was
pursuing them knowing that that would
allow their drug running and money
laundering operations to continue
unabated and therefore empower Hezbollah
that is a very monumental and I think
disastrous decision we need to know what
happened we need to know who told them
to stand down and then we also need to
get some of the architects of the Iran
deal like Ben Rhodes and see were they
involved with having DOJ shut this down
yeah
so right I'm glad that you followed up
on that because ben rhoades you know all
roads lead back to him because he's got
the answers he's the architect of a teen
it sounds like from his own words his
own admission he's making himself an
ideal subject of an investigation to
comply and come forward and proffer some
testimony to explain exactly what
transpired and remember he bragged about
creating a fake echo chamber where he
had the client journalists that would
put out disinformation about how this is
really capitalizing on an opening of the
Iranian regime they're gonna change and
become part of the community of nations
they knew that wasn't true they knew the
mullahs weren't changing they just
thought that given them a hundred and
fifty billion dollars in sanctions
relief airlifting over a billion dollars
to them in cash they thought that that
was good and that was the policy that
they pursued I think they'd pursued it
recklessly but by this investigation
we're gonna find out just how reckless
they were in doing that yeah I just
questioned that policy I questioned its
merits I questioned its authenticity
the whole Nexus of it how it came
together and what exactly did they think
that they were accomplishing was this
just some kind of like ego trophy to say
they could do this nuclear deal because
it was a bad deal for the United States
and now we know just how bad I think it
was exactly they wanted to hold up the
New York Times the next day and say oh
we had this great deal peace in our time
consequences be damned essentially and
if you think about the deal they never
did anything to prevent Iran from
developing ballistic missiles that's not
in the deal nothing about Iranian
support for terrorism and of course we
don't even have access to Iran's
military sites in this deal so it's
really a deal that empowered Iran
immediately and then paved the way for
Iran to develop nuclear weapons in the
fore in the near future it was a
disastrous deal but then you also see
now some of the consequences of that and
the collateral damage by empowering
Hezbollah and I think if you ask
somebody like Prime Minister Netanyahu
of Israel
yeah he's worried about groups like Isis
but I think he'd probably point to
Hezbollah as the most significant
terrorist group in his or neck of the
woods absolutely and he also tried to
point that out at the time when he was
stating his objections to the United
States making
because he knows full well who better
than he to determine and decide exactly
what's going on in that region
especially based on their excellent
intelligence gathering we already know
it we knew that was a bad deal at the
time but nevertheless it was pushed
forward and now we're finding out the
ramifications of it reminds me of The
Fast and Furious and covers up their
cover up there I mean it's unbelievable
because it just seems that they had a
specific political goal in mind and
acted against the best interests of the
United States and supported essentially
terrorism with Iran and Hezbollah and
funded it and probably on both ends with
by having the DEA stand down
that empower Hezbollah on the front end
but then when they're getting the
pallets of cash on the back end of the
deal
well why do you think they want the cash
because they want to give that to the
Revolutionary Guard Corps
they want to give it to group like
groups like Hezbollah so they can
continue to wreak havoc in the Middle
East so it was a disaster from the
beginning to end you're absolutely right
well I thank you for your service and
what you've done here and I look forward
to finding out the rest of this
information so obviously we need you to
come back a lot thank you very Christmas
Merry Christmas